hello and welcome back to bloodline the
taxonomy of fear where we discuss what
if anything makes a movie scary today
we'll be looking at game theory and how
it pertains in the movie would you
rather which stars Britney snow from
pitch perfect she was awesome in that
movie excellent in this movie she plays
a woman named iris who has a brother who
has leukemia and they have mounting
medical bills he's introduced to a
philanthropist who invites her and seven
other desperate guests to a dinner party
at which they have to play a game a
sadistic and sick person of would you
rather for a life-changing amount of
money and this movie also stars Rob
Wells from Trailer Park Boys as well as
Sasha Grey from the girlfriend
experience as well as several hundred
other titles you may or may not be
familiar with
would you rather electrocute yourself I
see where this is going what defines
game theory horror for us well at its
most basic game theory is about
strategic decision making and that their
most basic horror movies are about
making the right or relatable decision
and still ending up dead or completely
messed up a bad horror movie like this
one is when all the characters make the
stupidest decision decisions that we
would not make and end up dead because
we normally care about them because
they're idiots
would you rather and the second is
escalating stakes as the narrative goes
on there has to be more and more on the
line for you to be afraid of
and in this movie it just sort of starts
you off at a din of high threat level
and it doesn't really go up from there
because they can't so it the story
becomes monotonous they're not even it's
not even that high is coming well that's
it that's all there can be that's all
their deliberate yeah considering lives
are on the line you're never really that
engaged what's going to happen to people
and finally number three the game cannot
be unwinnable yes there has to be a
winner and in this movie there is a
winner but it certainly didn't feel like
at the end yeah it even robs you of the
satisfaction of you're given a winner
technically but it doesn't it takes all
the emotional resonance out of it
speaking of which hahaha
all right hours of sleep loss of Jordan
how many I'm gonna say two because
despite the fact that this movie didn't
really scare me at all
left me feeling super bummed out like I
lost a couple hours just feeling kind of
crummy about the world just have her
anyway well you were bummed I was mad I
lost about an hour because the ending
the ending was like the alternate ending
and the DVD extras this should not have
been the actual ending and then the
final blow I was like that's our payoff
that's it yeah this is our anti payoff
it is hard to sleep when you're pissed
all right horror movie survival lessons
Jordan what did you learn number one
money can't buy you happiness and
desperate times though they maybe don't
let dollar signs cloud your judgment
number two a failure to plan is a plan
to fail yes these people were given a
couple opportunities to congregate and
is cooperative game played not non
cooperative game play but they didn't
they just kind of let stuff happen they
did I didn't really even buy that they
wanted to be alive that badly
and number three rules are meant to be
broken if you're given option a and
option B and they both suck it's time to
creative problem solve and find option C
video pick of the week let me pick
1997's Cuba Canadian film where a bunch
of people wake up in these different
compartments have to figure out why
they're there the rules of the game and
how to survive because each compartment
is booby-trapped
that is my worst nightmare I'm awful at
puzzles that would be the end of me and
on the subject of worst nightmares I'm
gonna recommend compliance which was
made last year and directed by Craig
Sobel based on true events a prank
caller impersonates a police officer and
calls a fast-food restaurant manager and
gets her to perform increasingly
invasive interrogation techniques on a
young employee who theoretically stole
something it is paralyzing I could not
even deal with the preview for that
movie I wanted to turn it off like four
times but I just couldn't I had to sweat
it out till the end I was like a real
cop
so that's it for this week's episode of
bloodline email is that bloodline at
Wired com we'd like to hear from you and
as we like to say here at bloodline
remember it's just a game quick good
because I got this one
you